tu aura au moins un élément de
décoration qui fait penser à lise ça ne
va pas trop avec la couleur du millions
se trouvent soit c'était ça c'est à
marbella en bois de trois mètres de long
auquel tes insultes seront toujours en
créole merde
pardon langue et nos flacons 4 son aîné
de la fille garçon marraine tu interdire
à tes proches de boire du rhum entier
mathieu recrache ça tout de suite
pourquoi j'avais dit pas de romans
tiller chez moi une scie moins cher mais
je m'en fous que ce soit moins cher j'ai
une économie locale à préserver moi tu
feras de la publicité pour la réunion
dans toutes les conversations
c'est que tes prochaines vacances
devrait dépasser à la réunion on a nos
super abandonné chez nous mais on a de
très jolis roquain aussi tu prononcera
toujours à la réunionnaise vend déjà aux
avait conclu le principe on dit papa
yeoh dita payet à iec ce bon maintenant
de son numéro deux on dit pas litchi ont
dit les chip ok tu regarderas toutes les
émissions et reportages sur la réunion à
la télévision j'ai téléchargé dans les
game of thrones pour qu'on le regarde ce
sport annonce ce sens ça va pas être
possible à thalassa sur l'océan indien
et alors fanni va y avoir cinq minutes
sur la réunion qu'un multi plaisante
non on ne rate pas cinq minutes de
reportage sur la réunion auquel tu
hésitera toujours porté vacances partir
la découverte de l'europe pour rentrer à
la réunion la banque
je suis à découvert tu aura au moins un
tee shirt qui rappelle la réunion et en
plus un chat gay friendly qui existe en
plusieurs coloris tu utiliseras skype
pour communiquer avec tes proches maman
remonte l'écran parce que la mise
le clavier alors on vraiment là tu
recevras les côtés que tes amis tu
envoies pour ne pas payer de frais de
port trop cher et tuent les rangs vers
ensuite à l'eau brian où elle vous
rappelle caméscope ou la félibrée chez
moi là tu es comme il est désolé le beau
livre marié par mois sans un chien tu es
complètement cassé inutilisables ce
mythe en voyant toute une armée ennemie
est un an pour acheter un autre
tu écouteras avec nostalgie des vieilles
chansons réunionnaise et longs dimanches
d'hiver
merci
huit cent quarante mille habitants un
bout de rocher perdu dans l'océan indien
avec un drapeau français planté dessus
un an brocal en guise de cuisine une
population à l'adn complexe la réunion
c'est compliqué
chaque mois j'essaie justement
d'expliquer cette complexité dans des
vidéos que je diffuse sur youtube un
passe temps un peu spécial quand on y
pense un mec seul dans sa chambre face à
sa caméra pendant de l'intérêt du
rougail saucisses
comment j'en suis arrivée à vouloir
parler de la réunion sur youtube et les
montrer l'état de mon draps de lit tout
commence ici même à l'université de la
réunion plutôt à la fac de sciences
quand après avoir terminé mes études en
sociologie cailotto logis géologie je
décide de poursuivre mon cursus
universitaire en hexagone je n'étais ni
le premier ni le dernier jeune
réunionnais à vouloir jouer au jeu de la
mobilité
après tout nous étions 21e siècle les
stéréotypes sur legend et il n'existait
plus
les mains les métropolitains savait ce
que c'était que l'outre-mer et on
expédier plus les jeunes réunionnais en
creuse contre leur gré qu'est-ce que
j'étais naïf dans la nouvelle université
le premier jour à la toute première
heure de cours
un camarade de classe m'interpelle et me
dit ah tu viennes la réunion mais tu as
trop de la chance en fait quand tu étais
jeune quand avait fini les cours tu
pouvais aller à la plage et dormir sous
les cocotiers
alors étant originaire de saint-andré
ville connue pour sa pluviométrie vous
imaginez bien que l'âge et cocotiers
n'était pas les termes que j'aurais
employé pour qualifier mon enfance
d'autant qu'aujourd'hui le littoral de
ma commune est plus connu pour ses
débris d'avion que pour ces coquillages
je savais bien qu'un métropolitains ne
pouvait pas connaître toutes les
spécificités locales de l'île les
microclimats la côte au vent la côte
sous le vent mais je n'attendais pas une
vision aussi cartes postales
le pire c'est que mes autres camarades
c'est sûr mais aussi tout le monde m'a
posé plein de questions sur ma vie
quotidienne mais pour vous déplacer à la
réunion vous faites comment vous
utilisez des pirogues c'est ça la
réunion c'est bien lille qui utilisent
le franc pacifique c'est ce nom c'est
pas ça pour l'eau courante vous en avez
au moins vous n'êtes pas obligé d'aller
dans le puits du village pour récupérer
de l'eau alors ces questions pourrait
prêter à sourire et j répondait de
manière très polis mais parfois ça
allait carrément dans le débat et je
devais défendre la réunion quoi les
attaques de requins
ah non mais c'est pas si grave que ça en
fait si tu te bagne dans le lagon n'y a
pas trop de risques que ça va hein quoi
la secte du petit lys d'amour
non mais pas tous les réunionnais sont
des illuminés qui voit la vierge marie
d'élire un cocotier 1 n'est pas tous
comme ça je rassure en soirée j'étais le
réunionnais la personne référence pour
savoir ce que c'était que la vie en
outre-mer tous les gens venaient me voir
pour poser des questions un rôle auquel
je n'étais pas vraiment préparé puisque
à la base je me considère moi même comme
un mauvais réunionnais parce que je
n'aime pas une carie bichiques parce que
je suis jamais monté au sommet du piton
des neiges pas trouvé quelqu'un pour y
aller avec moi ambassadeur de la réunion
c'est un rôle auquel j'avais pas postulé
et qui ne m'allait pas réellement
néanmoins comme je voulais pas dire de
bêtises et que je voulais quand même
répondre aux questions de mes camarades
métropolitain eh ben j'ai dû me plonger
un peu plus dans l'histoire et la
culture de la réunion et vient ce moment
assez gênant ou à l'âge très avancé de
22 ans
j'écoute pour la toute première fois des
chansons de daniel waro
c'était donc ça bref c'est justement en
faisant ses recherches que j'ai compris
l'origine du problème pour comme mes
camarades métropolitain ans avait si peu
sur l'outre-mer
les livres reportage série télévisée
aussi étaient nombreux sur les
ultramarins mais il commettait quelques
erreurs déjà un gros amalgame que vous
soyez duy anh et réunionnais mayotte
mahorais pardon polynésiens ou saint
pierre remy on vous met tous dans le
même panier outre-mer gros amalgame
pourtant il ya beaucoup de différences
je me rappelle j'étais chez mon camarade
de classe justement le premier qui
m'avait parlé et je suis rentré dans sa
chambre mais j'ai vu un livre d'histoire
géographie qui datait du collège est
ouvert et alapage outre-mer une
magnifique photo d'une plage de bora
bora en polynésie
tu pensais vraiment que tout l'outre-mer
ressembler à ça ben oui pourquoi
avec son premier des questions sur les
pirogues malgré nos huit cent quarante
mille habitants nous manquons de
visibilité
faites le test quand vous partez en
hexagone poser la question métropolitain
est ce que tu pourrais imiter l'accent
réunionnais il vous fera un truc du
genre ah oui moi bien comprendre que
enlevé nyonnais assez vexant n'est-il
pas être confondu avec un entier et même
lorsqu un reportage était spécifiquement
et sur la réunion il manque un truc
pendant une heure et demie on nous
montrer nos pitons cirques et remparts
classés au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco
on nous montrait le piton des neiges on
nous montrait du canyoning on nous
montrait du surf on en montre plus
vraiment mais il manquait quelque chose
la vie quotidienne des réunionnais on ne
voyait pas quelqu'un tout simplement
prendre sa voiture pour aller au travail
on ne voyait pas un pique nique chemin
volcan on voyait pas on n'entendait pas
parler de radio freedom
comment peut-on faire un reportage d'une
heure et demie sur la réunion sans
mentionner radio freedom
impensable
bref je veux bien que pour promouvoir
l'île et promouvoir l'île et ne pas
faire fuir les touristes il ya certaines
choses qu'il ne vaut mieux pas montré
sur la réunion 1
vous imaginez le truc île de la réunion
venez découvrir nos magnifiques
embouteillages tous les lundis matin
dans l'échangeur de savanna saint paul
vous pourrez y admirer nos plantes
endémiques telles que cette magnifique
voiture peugeot 206 tuner de couleur
verte h ça serait la fin ça serait la
fin de l'économie locale néanmoins il
fallait trouver un juste milieu pas une
image très négative pas trop lisse et
trop car postal quelque chose y montrer
la région telle qu'elle est et c'est là
une idée germe dans l'esprit et six mois
en tant que réunionnais moyens je
parlais de ma vie quotidienne de ma
vision de la réunion alors j'étais un
jeune garçon innocent et plein de bonne
volonté
j'ai utilisé l'outil que tous les
garçons jeunes innocents et plein de
bonne volonté utiliser le blog internet
j'écrivais de longs articles vous
expliquant avec sarcasme humour et
ironie
l'intérêt du rougail saucisses je
pensais que ça allait intéresser les
gens de dire ça en trois ans d'existence
maximum de vue 100 par mois un immense
buzz
entre temps je rentre à la réunion
j'avais fini mes études et je découvre
les vidéos de normale sup rien sur
internet
des jeunes qui se filme comme fer dans
leurs chambres a raconté dans des petits
sièges leur vie quotidienne
et là je me rends compte de mon erreur
les gens n'ont pas envie de lire mes
longues tirades de cinq pages on est de
la génération y
il faut voir il faut entendre il faut
que ça bouge elle le petit lys d'amour
paca son pied coco
j'ai ma révélation la vidéo
la vidéo sur internet va être mon moyen
d'expression alors à ce stade j'ai le
message que je veux faire passer j'ai
l'outil de diffusion
il manque un truc ah oui le courage
c'est un peu difficile de se mettre en
avant sur internet surtout quand on
n'aime ni sa voix ni sa gueule ma mère à
vous dire que je ne suis pas le garçon
le plus moche de la terre il n'empêche
que je ne suis pas l'animateur télé 2010
ou écrire un texte pour un blog c'est
une chose faire le zouave devant une
caméra c'en est une autre
alors je m'interroge me pose le pour et
le contre et puis je me lance pas
capable est mort sans essayer je
commence d'abord par le faire les crocs
sur des sujets un peu simpliste histoire
de comprendre comment fonctionnent les
outils la caméra la lumière le son le
montage je rappelle qu'à la base je suis
roche log moi pas comprendre comment
caméra fonctionne une fois que je
maîtrise à peu près ces outils ben je
commence à m'attaquer à des sujets un
petit peu plus compliqué le créole
réunionnais les la cuisine réunionnaise
notre amour pour les voitures et radio
free dom d'affaires et là il se passe
quelque chose
le temps passe et il en petit land j'ai
de plus en plus d'abonnés
j'ai des commentaires positifs du genre
à il fait plaisir à entendre un moon
parle de la réunion de cette manière à y
fait trop gris chauffe trop le coeur en
tandem en cause créole qu'on l'est à
paris a dit me km et c'est là que je me
rends compte d'un truc j'ai une
révélation
moi qui au départ voulais juste parler
présenté la réunion mais camaret
métropolitain je touchais aussi les
réunionnais eux mêmes et surtout les
réunionnais qui étaient installés
ailleurs en hexagone à l'étranger ceux
pour qui internet était un lien
indispensable pour rester en contact
avec lille berceau grande révélation
n'est-il pas alors aujourd'hui je
de poursuivre ça j'essaie de continuer à
faire des vidéos en espérant que un
étudiant qui est seule à paris dans son
appartement de 5 mètres carrés pour ses
études
j'ai vécu dans 59 puisse regarder mes
vidéos et tout seul chez lui que ça
puisse moment il réchauffer le coeur
mais j'ai appris qu'en plus de connecter
les gens entre eux les vidéos
permettaient en tout cas me permettez de
parler de certains sujets avec un ton
que les médias traditionnels n'utilise
pas je suis actuellement un petit
youtuber douze mille abonnés c'est un
petit part d'internet mais un bond de
géant à l'échelle d'un étui et je me
rends compte du pouvoir de cette
plateforme on est encore tellement de
choses à faire là dessus
aujourd'hui nous n'avons nous avons tous
les outils nécessaires pour promouvoir
la réunion pas très loin
j'imagine que dans cette salle vous avez
quasiment tous un smartphone le cas je
vous invite à l'utiliser pas tout de
suite s'il vous plaît attendez que fermi
tripoli utilisé le et créent du contenu
sur la réunion prenez-vous en vidéo
prenez des photos écrivait des textes
parler de votre avis politique dans
certains débats parler de vos passions
montrer la vie quotidienne des
réunionnais multiplier le contenu sur la
réunion sur internet
ça permettra peut-être aux
métropolitains qu'enfin de recherches
sur l'île de découvrir d'autres choses
que les stéréotypes
il entend parler moi j'ai tenté le coup
j'ai commencé à faire des vidéos sur
internet seul dans ma chambre avec sa
passion un peu bizarre et finalement
j'en ai appris tellement sur moi même
déjà j'ai découvert que ben si je
mettais la caméra comme ça on voit pas
trop le début de calvitie à droite ça va
je suis à peu près beau gosse comme ça
mais j'en ai appris également sur la
réunion elle-même parce que chaque vidéo
me demandent des recherches sur l'île et
je me pose après des questions hyper
philosophique
pourquoi est ce qu'on mange
essentiellement du riz dans l'île alors
que braid patate magnan qui pousse plus
facilement si quelqu'un a la réponse
aujourd'hui grâce à tout ça j'ai
beaucoup plus des ans pour présenter la
réunion à n'importe quel interlocuteur
en hexagone je prend même plaisir à lui
qu'est ce que c'est qu'il
alors qu'au départ c'était quand même
très timide maintenant je peux aller
n'importe où je te présenter la réunion
à n'importe qui enfin presque n'importe
qui je vous dis encore du mal avec les
anglophones
parce que le hello à came from réunion
island in you don't know very les noms
de dooyoo nos orgueils soucis ce nom
do you know américain bah c'est pas
gagné d affaires
si vous avez aimé cette prestation vous
pouvez cliquer sur j'aime partager cette
vidéo vous abonner à la chaîne et
laisser un commentaire
m